[Musique]
ben non
vous l'a dit mais les messieurs peu
animé bernard qui est un grand
professionnel à tello va voir s'ils
croient à jean-michel panne et où on
peut pas être pire que castaldi du poids
c'est ça vous laissera pas faire oui
d'accord allait proposer dans l'émission
d'hier
voilà deux des changes est la sanction
du csa contre un versement des pubs
normale pour les associations comme le
voyez tout de suite un décodeur connais
mes conversations reprenait tout depuis
début vous vous asseyez et vous relaie
jean-michel le point c'est ça si l'on
peut pas faire un petit coin csa vous
aviez proposé hier j'étais pas très
intelligent de votre part des voilà que
la sanction soit transformé les pubs
reviennent enfin reste sur les missions
et qu'en revanche l'argent le bénéfice
des pubs soit reversée aux associations
comme les anges de la rue les restos du
coeur mais ça beaucoup plus intelligent
rêve pour les regrets pour les enfants
etc
et monsieur schrameck si vous faites ça
en plus je vous offrirai des dvd de
shrek
voilà puisque c'est moi depuis vous êtes
animateur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]